à gauche
sackey suivant
alors c'est bon toi
ils sont restés derrière la rentrée
rentrée by ap ap ou là
son tour président
elle a voté sa bosse en retour voir
dépêche
continuez continuez vous arrêtez pas
vous arrêtez pas continuez encore
j'ai bien regardé ça qui te faut oui
franchement tu l'équipe maintenant je
suis d'accord de payer moi je dirais tu
au jeu très fort aux lyonnais moi je
suis visagiste visagie
franchement
[Musique]
en mai mais je te jure que des niveaux
pas changé
m
[Musique]
tranquillement mais des habitants côté
de la droite par la panique lorsque tu
es là le téléphone sommes serviront à
161 le téléphone quatre gardes du corps
qui lui comment il dit à puce désolé on
va le monde
vous avez un incroyable
angers 100% que c'est fini mais grâce à
nick lowe à vincent duclos il a quand
même du charme
[Musique]
comme diego de la vega au niveau de la
mer au bobino
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous avons gagné de jouer parfait et
marc occupe pas
[Musique]